so you're an American defense contractor
in the late 1980s you've been making
good money for years selling weapons and
equipment to the US military World War
II the Korean War the Vietnam War and of
course the Cold War were all very good
for business but lately things have been
quiet the Cold War had already peaked
which left you without any big orders
for all your fancy bombs and planes so
somehow you needed to find a way to
boost your profits but then something
magical happens out of the blue the
Pentagon and Congress wanted to make
reducing defense equipment easier so
they did something unexpected they
called for the defense industry to merge
to go from hundreds of small contractors
to just a few industry Giants see
typically the government wants to break
up monopolies Standard Oil American
Tobacco and even at T's monopolies have
been hunted down and destroyed but here
was the same government demanding that
you monopolize possibly the worst
industry to have a monopoly in they were
convinced that they could rely on the
companies to do what was in the best
interest of the war Fighters and the
taxpayers well jokes on them because
with the government supports you created
a monopoly so big so strong that the US
government and subsequently the U.S
citizen would have no other choice but
to just bend over and take it to the
tune of billions of dollars per year
today the military industrial complex is
arguably more powerful than America
itself and it all spiraled out of
control after this one single decision
stay dangerous and this is the
monopolization of America's military
industrial complex
thank you
and by the way guys a lot of you guys
are probably sitting down right now as
you're watching this but did you know
that sitting down is actually one of the
worst things in the world aside from the
risk of looking like this when you're
older sitting down too much according to
Yale medicine can lead to cancer weight
gain heart disease vascular problems and
of course lower back pain and spine
issues and it makes sense humans were
just not meant to be sitting down as
much and that is why I recommend you get
a standing desk I've been using standing
desk for six years now and aside from
cutting out artificial food getting a
standing desk is one of the best hacks
out there for improving your health and
the brand I recommend is flexi spot
flexi spot was one of the best standing
desk by techradar and they're
recommended by YouTubers like Linus Tech
tips what I love about flexi spot is
that compared to other brands that I've
tried their touchpad is super responsive
and fast the desktop comes with
pre-drilled holes so you don't need a
drill they have a ton of different
colors sizes and accessories to choose
from and the actual Motors are strong
enough to do this so do your body a
favor and pick up your own standing desk
by scrolling down and clicking the link
below scroll down and click the link
below to get your own standing destiny
now as the flexi spot for sponsoring
this video
foreign
there was so little demand for new
weapons and so much new competition that
it left you as a defense contractor
super super desperate and you were
willing to do anything to land a
contract that is the problem with World
Peace gone were the days of making easy
money from work for the past 10 years
you were just begging for scraps hoping
you wouldn't go bankrupt but then in
1993 everything changed see over the
past decade it hadn't been just defense
contractors that were feeling the heat
of budget cuts but the Pentagon in a DOD
were feeling it too at the time it could
easily take five to six different
companies just to make one little
missile which was obviously a very
expensive time-consuming process that
was also a threat to National Security
ding ding ding so the speed of the
production process saved money and to
give the American contractors a better
chance at competing with the Europeans
the Pentagon came up with a plan a
merger get the 50 biggest defense
contractors to sit down at a table and
to get them to merge into just a few
giant companies that way that same
missile that took five different
companies to make before could be
produced quickly and easily with just
one company the merger was supposed to
make America's biggest defense
contractors more competitive and
efficient but you had other plans see it
didn't take very long for you and your
defense buddies to realize that you have
been given the opportunity of a lifetime
here was the government personally
giving you permission to do what every
other industry could only dream of Curry
a monopoly so that's exactly what you
did 51 major contractors Consolidated to
five giants 51 of the biggest and best
American defense companies merged to
form just five Mega corporations
Lockheed Martin Norfolk Grumman Boeing
General Dynamics and Raytheon
Technologies at first your little
Monopoly seemed perfectly innocent you
will supplied the Pentagon and the US
military with weapons and equipment and
get a very reasonable 15 profit in
return that was a deal but you were
running a monopoly remember and one has
a Monopoly ever been fair and reasonable
sure the Pentagon in a DOD had only
agreed to 15 profits but they have
gotten one little detail by letting you
monopolize your cartel of five companies
had all the leverage now who was the
government to tell you what to charge so
you proceeded to take the US government
and Military for a ride a very long very
expensive ride that they would never be
able to get off of
foreign
[Music]
1991 one shoulder fire stinger missile
cost 25 000 adjusting for inflation
that's around 55 000 in 2023 but today
that same missile costs over four
hundred thousand dollars and that did
not happen by accidents take the Patriot
missile system for example today the
sole manufacturer of the Patriot missile
system is Raytheon and the only
companies that make the actual missiles
the Patriot system fires are Lockheed
Martin and Boeing no one else on Earth
knows how to build this missile system
or the actual missiles it uses for the
US government that is a problem but for
you it's a massive opportunity see the
Patriot missile system is one of
America's most important defensive
weapons without it we would not be able
to track and shoot down enemy planes or
missiles that enter American airspace
and you knew that America needs Patriot
missiles to keep the country safe SSU
and your other defense Monopoly buddies
are the only ones that manufacture them
you can just charge whatever you want
for the Patriot missile system and the
American taxpayers would just have to
cough up the cash so instead of taking a
reasonable 15 profit on each Patriot
missile you built you decide to push a
profit margin to almost 40 that means
for each four million dollar Patriot
missile you produce you're taking home
almost 1.6 million dollars in pure
profits for just one missile but 40 is
just the beginning it's still Child's
Play this bill is an oil pressure switch
that NASA used to buy well their oil
switched with all of the cabling cost
328 dollars this oil switch we paid over
ten thousand dollars for it in 2012 he
was tapped to take the reins of the
troubled F-35 Joint Strike Fighter
program it was seven years behind
schedule and 90 billion dollars over the
original estimate but bognan told us the
biggest costs are yet to come for
support and maintenance which could end
up costing taxpayers 1.3 trillion
dollars we won't be able to buy as many
f-35s as we thought
because it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to buy air more airplanes when you
can't afford the ones you have
the Pentagon had seated control of the
program to Lockheed Martin the
contractor is delivering the aircraft
the Pentagon paid to design and build
but under the contract Lockheed and its
suppliers retain control of design and
repair data the proprietary information
needed to fix and upgrade the plane
so you spend billions and billions of
dollars to get this plane built and it
doesn't actually belong to the
Department of Defense the weapon system
belongs to the department but the data
underlying the design of the airplane
does not we can't maintain and sustain
the planes without
Lockheed correct so and that's because
we didn't up front either buy or
negotiate getting the technical data we
needed so that when a part breaks
the dod can fix it themselves the
Pentagon had made an expensive mistake
and you were nowhere near done with them
thank you
see as a defense contractor you don't
have the time or tools to build every
single little part that goes into every
gun missile or plane you sell so you
Outsource a lot of that work to smaller
companies called subcontractors and
these subcontractors also followed in
your Footsteps in the 1990s some of
these subcontractors also saw their
chance to make a lot of money by merging
and so that's exactly what they did and
one company that did this really well is
transdyne transdime is responsible for
manufacturing the parts for military
aircraft like the Apache helicopter F-16
jet and the ch-47 Chinook in fact that
the only company that can produce a lot
of the small parts and as the only
subcontract that can produce those parts
this company has made literally billions
massively overcharging the Pentagon for
all of them instead of the pathetic 50
profit margin the Pentagon sees as
acceptable Trends on his profit margins
actually range from 17 to a whopping 4
451 Yes you heard that right at 4 451 in
2006 Shay Assad says Apache helicopters
were unable to fly without a crucial
valve transdime had taken over the
manufacturer and hiked the price of the
valve by 747 up almost 40 percent
we said look we need these parts
to go on aircraft that are in Iraq they
simply said we're not going to ship it
until you cough up to the battlefield
that's correct this was going to the
battlefield by 2018 the valve would grow
to cost almost twelve thousand dollars a
pentagon report called it extortion
so explain to me
why can't the Department of Defense just
step up to transdime and say no
we're not going to pay that because we
don't have another source for a lot of
the spares that they provide right now
they are the literally only game in town
in order to make an aircraft fly so
we're at their Mercy does that make
sense to any of you and it is very
concerning to me contractors see that
they can do this they are the ones that
hold the power so it's not really a a
true capitalistic Market because one
company is telling you what's going to
happen so if it's not a capitalistic
system what is it
yeah
last year transdon made a nice 5 billion
dollars while they're stuck it's a
healthy nearly 900 a share so as you can
see it pays the price gouge but to the
big five defense contractors like Boeing
you really don't mind that they're price
gouging you because by overcharging you
you get to overcharge the Pentagon even
more now I can already hear you saying
but Jake as an American company
shouldn't your first priority be the
Safety and Security of our troops
instead of squeezing the government for
every penny they have
yes sure but there is one downside to
this see obviously scamming the Pentagon
in broad daylight is gonna make you a
lot of enemies so when the public and
government officials eventually start
sharpening their pitchforks you gotta
take the only logical path you gotta
gather your best and brightest lobbyists
and send them to Capitol Hill
[Music]
every year dozens of Pentagon and DOD
employees leave the government to join
the defense contractors giving you all
The Insider information and contacts you
need to keep America's defense budget
growing and the Monopoly thriving over
the past 20 years you've spent more than
2.5 billion dollars on the legal bribery
that is lobbying which is a pretty good
deal when you consider that just one of
the big five contractors already make
over 67 billion dollars on a single year
honestly you could afford to Lobby even
more if you needed to with this measly
2.5 billion dollars you were able to
employ an average of 700 lobbyists every
single year that's more than one
lobbyist for every member of Congress
for just a teeny tiny fraction of the
amount of money you made and they know
exactly how to appeal to the people in
power just tell the public that's for
National Security no one's going to
question this once for the troops in
Iraq or Afghanistan or even the poor
helpless civilians in Ukraine are you
really stressing over a few thousand
dollars when American men and women are
dying in Iraq are you gonna let
democracy fall in Ukraine over a couple
billion dollars and this argument has
worked every single time it's worth so
well that in 2011 the estimated amount
of money lost because of waste or
overcharging from contracts for Iraq and
Afghanistan totaled between 30 and 60
billion dollars 30 to 60 billion dollars
that you were able to grift straight
into your pockets and that was 12 years
ago how much could that number be now we
don't really know and you want to keep
it that way which brings us to our next
step
foreign
deny transparency ever since the 1990s
annoying government officials have
always been nagging you overseeing your
receipts according to the government any
military equipment sold to the Pentagon
should have a clear record of what it
costs to produce which could be a bit of
a problem considering you don't want to
settle for that sad 50 profit they're
offering you luckily you have the
perfect solution label your products for
commercial use instead of just military
use see defense contractors don't only
Supply the military wear products they
also make planes equipment and tools for
commercial use and Commercial products
fall under completely different rules as
a free market country no one can demand
a company publicize what it costs them
to make commercial products or else
their competitors could easily use that
information to copy their products or
beat their prices you don't ask the car
dealer at the grocery store and pizza
parlor for cost data no you buy based on
your assessment of the best price and
fair value the Pentagon can do the same
for commercial Source items thanks to
this rule you could just classify as
many of your products as possible as
commercial and no one would ever be able
to ask you what they really cost reduce
so you got a little creative with your
product descriptions sure this valve is
the only thing that can make those
Apache helicopters fly but it's also a
really important component in commercial
planes so you technically can't ask us
what it really costs so that would be
ten thousand dollars thank you and with
that last little problem solved you
finally get to sit back and enjoy the
fruits of the American taxpayers labor
foreign
[Music]
the money is pouring in and life is
better than ever but like all
billionaires no amount of money is ever
good enough for you you have to take it
one step further you've had to find a
way to make even more so you add one
last step to your master plan instead of
using all that taxpayer money the
government gives you to improve or
update your products just use it to buy
back shares to make yourself even richer
a Department of Defense study released
last month found major contractors flush
with tens of billions of Pentagon
dollars to hand out to shareholders
2021 the top five defense contractors
received more than 116 billion dollars
in Pentagon contracts that's 116 of your
money in the form of taxes and how much
money did their CEOs take home between
18 million and 23 million each in total
the big fat top Executives were paid
more than a quarter of a billion dollars
we were literally paying taxes so these
corrupt Executives can live lives of
total luxury and the worst part is that
there's nothing the government can do
about it except spend even more in March
the Pentagon announced its largest
budget ever
842 billion dollars almost half will go
to defense contractors
see everyone knows about the war in
Ukraine and how profitable that's been
from the military industrial complex but
did you know that there's another secret
American war going on right now that is
arguably much worse than Ukraine a
secret war that has been going on for
nearly 10 years that's killed over 377
000 people 60 of which die from
starvation drinking unsafe water or not
being able to get medical care a war
that some call the greatest humanitarian
crisis on the planet right now and yet
while America sits back and calls Putin
evil you never hear a word about this
war in the news you don't hear about any
billion dollar Aid packages going to
help these poor people nothing why
because in this secret War America is
the evil one and what war is this the
war in Yemen and why is America involved
in this war because of one reason and
one reason only to keep the Saudi royal
family happy and we expose all of
America's misdees in the Yemen war in
our new private documentary that is
definitely too spicy to be posted
publicly in fact it's already age
restricted and you can watch it right
now by clicking the card on the screen
click the card on the screen to watch
now
foreign